j'aimerais commencer par vous proposer
de vous rappeler d'un rapport sexuel qui
vous a fait du bien fermez les yeux et
visualiser le est-ce que c'était doux
est-ce que c'était chez vous dans la
nature
est-ce que vous en avez reparlé avec la
personne concernée ou avez vous pu
partager ce moment avec les personnes de
votre entourage
pour ma part la dernière fois que j'ai
fait l'amour
j'étais avec la personne que j'aime avec
qui je partage ma vie on était mieux au
lit on s'embrassait vous pouvez imaginer
la suite
en fait non pourquoi la pornographie
existerait tél
si on pouvait simplement toujours
imaginer la suite du coup je vais vous
raconter ce qu'il s'est passé on était
nu au lit en s'embrasser et je me suis
mis sur elle j'avais ma cuisse entre ses
jambes et en m'appuyant contre elle
je pouvais sentir son excitation qui
montait au même rythme que la mienne en
voulant devra dresser pour l'embrasser
je glisse je m'étale sur elle et ça nous
fait rire
vous voyez ces moments qui ne font pas
partie des films pornos si je mobilise
votre imagination comme entrée en
matière de ce toc c'est que j'aimerais
vous proposé de développer votre
imaginaire pour qu'ils s'éloignent du
manuel des rapports sexuels que nous
montre la pornographie meanstream
aujourd'hui est de se réapproprier son
corps et ses pratiques
c'est là l'un des objectifs sur lesquels
je travaille avec une production
production est une boîte de production
pornographique alternative fondée en
2018 ce qui nous unit dans ce collectif
c'est notre volonté de démystifier les
sexualités de créer du contenu explicite
qui soit pour tout le monde est de le
faire de façon éthique
ce qui est important dans les films
qu'on réalise ses deux premières me
répondre à certains critères qui sont en
marge de ce que l'on retrouve
habituellement dans la pornographie
disons classique notamment et notion de
consentement de représentation des corps
des sexualités des désirs lfc fps on
entend par ces espèces
un espace bienveillant dans lequel on se
sent à l'aise de dire non si quelque
chose ne convient pas ou plus et où
l'identité des personnes impliquées et
respectées et valorisées
vous êtes vous déjà posé ces questions
autant que ce soit dans ce que vous avez
pu voir sur internet ou expérimentés
avec votre corps l'une de mes volontés
en tant que personne qui produit du
contenu explicite éthique est de
promouvoir une éducation sexuelle
basé sur le consentement est le plaisir
je sais pas pour vous mais entendre mes
parents faire l'amour quand j'étais
petit c'était quelque chose de très
gênant mais est-ce que c'était parce que
j'étais mal à l'aise face à l'expression
de leur désir ou parce qu'il fermait la
porte de leur intimité au sens propre
comme figuré ce qui m'empêchait
d'entamer une compréhension de la
sexualité entre adultes vous voyez cette
intimité sacrée au sein des familles
hétéronormée celle qui se veut
incontestable est secrète
pourtant vous aurez peut-être remarqué
que lorsqu'une personne vit une
sexualité hors de ce cadre défini
elle est souvent marginalisés et appelé
à s'identifier au travers de cette
dernière
exemple personnel j'ai dû dans ma vie
faire de coming out le premier lorsque
j'ai dit à mon entourage que je suis
homosexuel est le suivant pour annoncer
que je suis une personne trans non
binaire pourquoi ce besoin de définir
mon genre et ma sexualité alors que si
j'étais un homme si ce genre
hétérosexuels jamais je ne serai allé
devant mes parents pour leur dire papa
maman je suis un homme et je couche avec
des femmes on se doit de révéler sa
sexualité dès qu'elle sort des normes
établies par les schémas 6 hétérosexuels
6 ça veut dire que le genre ressenti
d'une personne correspond genre assigné
à sa naissance si je vous parle de tout
ça c'est parce que ces éléments sont
essentiels dans la mort ce de notre
compréhension à la sexualité
cette dernière est en fortement
lacunaire entre en jeu la pornographie
on va pas se le cacher parler de sexe
est quelque chose de plutôt tabou il est
donc plus facile de se tourner vers son
ordinateur est de traverser le portail
certifiant de notre majorité légale
autrement dit ouvrir un site porno que
de parler à son entourage
celui-là même auquel vous n'avez
certainement pas évoqué cette fameuse
aventure que je vous propose une aide
que je vous proposais d' imaginer il ya
quelques instants car ce qu'est la
pornographie nous propose c'est un accès
libre à l'intimité d'un d'inconnu
autrement dit à la sphère privée sur un
espace public sans tabou c'est un peu
comme avoir accès à la réserve du bar du
coin
il ya toutes les boissons pour tous les
goûts et dans des quantités
astronomiques mais surtout vous pouvez
vous servir sans être vu imaginez
maintenant que ce bar doivent accueillir
42 milliard de visites par année ce qui
fait environ 115 millions par jour ces
chiffres indiquent temps fait la
fréquentation d'un site porno populaire
aujourd'hui pour contenter une telle
audience
l'offre qui se voulait peut-être
qualitative un moment donné se retrouve
entraîné dans les rouages d'un système
de surconsommation propre au capitalisme
à ce rythme nos désirs se retrouvent
façonné par l'industrie du porno
ce que nous proposons avec hull
production
c'est de ralentir le rythme de créer des
films à échelle humaine et dans des
conditions définies pour ce faire le
processus de production se veut donc
éthiques
c'est à dire que nous travaillons avec
des personnes et des institutions qui
partagent nos valeurs et qui ont pour
ambition de respecter l'intégrité de
chaque personne
cela passe par la rémunération des
personnes impliquées l'application du
droit de regard des conditions de
travail saines et valorisante ainsi qu'
une écoute attentive mais aussi une
distribution réfléchit qui ne passe pas
par les sites connus
quitte à perdre en visibilité si on
considère le porno comme un produit
consommation alimentaire nous le
préférons bio et local et c'est pour ça
que notre pratique diverge de ce que
l'on retrouve dans l'industrie du porno
comme j'ai déjà dit si on veut que ce
prono soit bio et local
ça passe par le respect de certains
principes que l'on retrouve dans notre
charte
j'ai déjà énuméré ces derniers
auparavant mais je voulais répéter car
ils sont essentiels pour comprendre ce
que j'entends par la production de
pornographie alternative le cfp
l'éthique la représentation des corps
des sexualités et des désirs un cycle
consentement sur le principe de cette
charte nous a permis de nous rendre
compte de l'importance d'avoir un espace
de parole dans lequel on peut librement
par les deux sexes un espace dans lequel
il ne s'agit pas de juger mais de
comprendre de pouvoir partager ses
expériences et ses fantasmes dans un
contexte déconstruit et attentif
maintenant revenons un peu à vous quels
sont les tabous qui vous anime
quelles sont ces choses dont vous ne
pouvez pas parler à votre entourage
si je fais du porno aujourd'hui c'est
parce que je regardais et regard
toujours pour être honnête
beaucoup de porno parfois soutiens mon
imaginaire lorsque je me masturbe ou
simple curiosité regarder du contenu
explicite fait partie de ma vie depuis
un certain nombre d'années
et figurez vous que c'est précisément en
2017 lorsque j'étais en erasmus à
bologne que j'ai eu le déclic je me
masturber devant un film plutôt mauvais
dont la scène fila ne m'a pas plu et je
me suis dit il ya certainement une
meilleure façon de faire ce genre de
film
c'est en fait à cause de l'absence
d'interrogation face à la pornographie
qui se fait et à laquelle on est soumis
que s'est développé mon envie d'en faire
afin de pouvoir la déconstruire
quand vous voyez un épisode d'une série
qui vous a plu vous avez généralement
envie d'en parler à votre entourage afin
de pouvoir en débattre et partager ce
que vous avez vu et c'est ça qui fait
défaut aux images pornographiques
aujourd'hui le sens critique qui nous
permet de comprendre ce que l'on voit la
pornographie mainstream comme la
publicité nous a devancé et à façonner
nos désirs avant même que nous puissions
les conscientiser cette dernière est
révélatrice d'une société dans laquelle
on lève de la société dans laquelle on
évolue une société patriarcale
hétéronormée et occidentale au centre et
dans laquelle capitalisme et sexualité
trouve dans la promotion de toutes
choses
l'expression d'une proximité complices
qui nous divertit de l'essentiel
en découle donc malheureusement un
contenu largement consommée d'image
violente raciste transphobes et bien
d'autres problèmes encore son qu'aucun
espace de médiation ne soit fournie en
témoignent les tags ou les catégories
problématique sur les sites pornos qu'on
retrouve avec eux je ne vais pas
énumérer ici en connaissance de ces
éléments
elle réagit en produisant ces films dans
un espace de confiance ce qui est
important pour nous ce n'est pas le
profit mais de travailler avec des
personnes qui nous intéresse sur les
plans humain et artistique afin de
pouvoir créer un échange soulever ces
problématiques et surtout provoqué lé
envie de se masturber au début de ce
taux qui j'ai partagé avec vous le bref
récit de ma dernière aventure
cet exercice est la transposition de la
sphère privée sur un espace public
c'est une intimité mise en scène mais
une intimité
quand même le fait produire du porno
alternatif est important au sens où il
n'y a pas qu'un seul fantasme mais
plusieurs et donc plusieurs types de
pornographie néanmoins cette dernière ne
doit pas cette dernière ne doit pas être
une réalité absolue mais plutôt un
soutien à l'imaginaire c'est pour ça
qu'il est important de consommer tout
contenu explicite de manière lucide d'en
parler afin de pouvoir sont détachés et
construire librement nos fantasmes
je vous parle de tout ça avec certaines
une certaine facilité sauf le moment
j'ai oublié mon texte parce que j'évolue
dans ce milieu depuis plusieurs années
mais je me rends bien compte qu'il n'est
pas toujours aisé de parler de sexe et
ce n'est pas forcément faute de volonté
mais que l'impact de traumatismes passés
ou même de contextes socioculturels
différents ne sont pas toujours propice
à ce discours aussi anodin que cela
puisse paraître libérer la rapport la
parole sur les rapports sexuels positif
permet par extension d'aborder les
expériences négatives
celle où le consentement fait défaut car
nos corps ne sont pas seulement des
vaisseaux de chair qui nous permettent
de se transporter mais c'est surtout ce
qui nous permet de vivre est de
ressentir des expériences personnelles
et profonde oeil productions a changé ma
vie en m'ouvrant à une communauté queer
sexe positive où la communication est au
centre où les sentiments des uns et des
autres peuvent être exprimés librement
où les émotions ne sont pas réprimés mes
ressentis et partager être conscient de
ça est une force qui me permet d'évoluer
au quotidien au sein d'une société et
d'un système qui ne me reconnaisse pas
les mêmes droits que les personnes 6
hétérosexuels une société où n'importe
quel paul de diffuser ces propos qui
encourage la culture du viol sans aucune
conséquence
j'aimerais terminer en disant que les
notions abordées lors de ce taux qui ne
correspondent peut-être pas à la réalité
du grand public mais une vision que nous
avons de cette dernière et qui nous
pousse à la remise en question des
schémas établis
mon souhait avec vous aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas de changer vos vies mais de
vous rendre conscients de vos corps et
de vos désirs d'apprendre ensemble et
dans la bienveillance a construit des
relations saines où chaque personne se
sent aimé et valoriser le temps d'une
nuit ou pour la vie
merci
[Applaudissements]